[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's okay well great
great to hear from you i saw your post
on social media suggested your book of
course so
here we are you see i've seen that
you've got some questions
around finding
[Music]
email it's investors um so um
i sent out some emails to people so i
a solicitor i've got my own well i did
have my own law firm closed as a result
i just emailed a few clients um
he lives in russia he's got a few
businesses in the uk he's asked me to
locate lan for him to fill 250 houses
and and if i can do that some of his
friends want to invest in different
things
um and i've got i've just had a call
with some invest
three investors this morning who now
want me to be their deal saucer
and they're just asking they're quite
interested in one of the properties and
so i've just put an offering on
that but it's that one it's on the
market for 350
and so or you could it just means
modernizing
um so i think i could make quite a bit
of money on deal sourcing on just
that deal as it comes through and
so yeah i have um i only started last
week my first week's not over yet but
i'm just
any advice or anything that you can give
me
and particularly this larger deal i
would greatly appreciate it
that's cool great well one of the
reasons i wanted to take your call was
because i could see that you were
taking massive action and stuff and you
were you know had had good high energy
and i just thought i'm going to jump on
this call myself
um but i mean i do jump on quite a lot
of the calls but not
obviously every call so okay so let me
ask you a question so
literally like when we spoke on social
media a couple days ago you were saying
that you were struggling to get
investors and stuff like that
and now already you're saying that's not
so much an issue
what did you do to get these investors
like what happened
okay so um i don't know so wednesday was
my first day last week
and i think i popped that post on either
wednesday or thursday
um and i put a couple of posts on social
media
basically um with the deals that i found
um just summarizing what you were asking
if anybody
would be interested and sent a couple of
emails to people i knew in my personal
network
just asking if they knew anyone who um
ever invested in property
um and that the first
day or two was really slow but by the
end of
the thursday absolutely which was the
second day my inbox was just pinking i'm
kinking and pinking
and friday morning i got this email from
the russians saying
that the small profit is a great sample
i wanted to buy some land to build a
property of 250 houses
and i was like oh okay um
and then yeah it kind of just snowballs
from that my phone has not stopped
you know weekend i've got 10 calls
registered today with different
investors
and i just have one estate agent agreed
to put me on so you'll give me
deals two days before they go on market
um
so yeah it's kind of just gone sounds
like it sounds like it's flying
so so so the 250 house thing that's an
investor that said they
want that not a deal that you found
that's just someone that's saying that
that's what they're looking for is that
right
yes okay cool what i would probably do
as well and it's interesting it's
probably the right
way around so i think it's more
effective finding investors first and
then going finding them something
rather than just refining a random deal
and then desperately trying to find an
investor for that deal
so you've i mean you've already got have
you actually got any deals already in
the bag you said because you said you
posted some deals on social media
so this property well you could probably
earn over 100
000 just by investing and selling it
and the two sisters have refused to take
any more viewings
um but i've just said to the estate
agent look i've got cash buyers they
said that they can complete
in two weeks there's no chain and i just
need
basically what they've done is they've
extended it to the loft and
well even i said i just said the client
on the phone i said look
even worst case scenario if you get it
as a three bed
i said the one that sold at 485
wasn't three bed and how much have you
got it for
350. right nice okay
so so if that sounds great so you've got
investors
that are interested wanting to pay you
money you've got deals
and you've got property opportunities so
what do you need
what do you need from me right now um
well i suppose so
um this one with the russian is scaring
the hell out of it because obviously
i kind of told him i was starting off
anyway so he knows i'm a bit of a novice
[Music]
because they're all her clients so she
sent me about 10 emails this morning
giving me introductions which is great
i'm worried that if the russian comes
back so now i've got this introduction
i think i'm going to be able to source
the land in manchester
or liverpool quickly i just don't know
what to do so i'm thinking can you help
me in any way
hold him because i don't want obviously
i want to do a good impression so he
uses me again
and i think he comes to me because he
trusts me and
he said that if we can do it he's got
friends that want to invest
in the uk and in property and things
yeah
i'm just thinking well i think that's
what i'm doing
what does he actually want okay a couple
things
is what does he want and is he serious
those are the two things that i want to
know so firstly what does he want what's
he actually looking for
a piece of land he can build 250 houses
on or is he looking for a particular
amount of net
he can build up to profits houses if
it's unless he'll still consider it or
ideally up to
250 houses is that he is interested in
the smaller deals but that
he wants the development not kind of
flip deals
and what kind of profit is he wanting to
make and where is he looking
um so he ideally wants it in manchester
because he
the area's booming possible liverpool
but i ideally manchester
um we've not mentioned about profit
i know he's quite a high net worth
individuals and
so yeah
because he'll be he'll be he'll be
looking for a bit i imagine if he's a
good
if he's a smart investor he'll be
looking for a particular he won't just
be looking for a piece of land where he
can build 200 houses because
anyone can buy a piece of land and build
200 houses on it but
you got to be able to actually make
money on it so it's about finding an
opportunity where you can make money
i mean the second second question as
well because the last
one of the things that i've seen a lot
of people do is they have an investor
that says they've got millions of pounds
and they're looking for something
huge and then the deal saucer goes out
spends
two three weeks busting a gut trying to
find something only to realize that
actually the investor is
you know really picky or hasn't even got
money at all
he's he's a deal sorcerer himself that's
looking for some other and
you actually get caught up in a daisy
chain of you know you just
so what i would probably do is i'd say
to him look i'll happily search for
something for you
um can i see your phones and can you
outline exactly what kind of profit
you're expecting to make
can i see some id yeah
and if he won't give you that then it's
a big red flag
last week
i think
because you were saying is it too much
to expect people to give id and my
thinking is absolutely not
if you're wanting to have a serious
relationship with somebody and you're
going to spend
weeks trying to find them a deal with
zero confirmation that they're actually
going to
buy the deal once you find it at least
they can do is give you some
some form of id and proof of funds if
you're an estate agent and you go around
saying to an estate agent i'm looking to
buy this
the first thing they'll say is i want to
see i want to see um
proof of funds so it's no different
so i've been wanting to see that and it
wouldn't surprise me if this russian guy
won't give it to you and if he won't
give it to you then it probably means
that he hasn't actually got the money
okay so that's next right
let's say he goes all right here's one
proof of funds and he shows you've got
three million in the bank
he's got um photo id
and all is good then i would say to him
awesome
so my um russian investor friend
whatever his name is
um what what i'll do now is i'm gonna
spend the next
uh three to four weeks trying to find
you
the perfect investment opportunity now
if i don't find it to you that's fine
but what i want to do just to get a
little bit of commitment up front
is i want to take a um a 2 000
deposit off you up front and then i'm
going to spend four weeks trying to find
you something now if i don't find you
anything that fits the bill
we're going to have terms and conditions
in place that says that your 2000
deposit will be refunded to you after
four weeks
or you can renew it to another four
weeks but that's your progressive
if i do find something suitable for you
and you like it
then you can pay the outstanding balance
of the finance fee whatever
whatever that figure is that you agree
and in that way you're not frantically
rushing around
for people like a headless chicken that
aren't actually gonna buy
anyway and most people if i'm if i'm an
investor and
i've got three million and you're going
to spend
weeks of your time hunting for a perfect
deal for me
i'll give you 2 000 pounds up front
and the only reason i wouldn't would be
because i thought i didn't believe in
you i thought that you weren't
you know great but if i if i thought
that i'm not going to buy off you anyway
so it's a whole waste of time so it's
almost like a bit of
we call it a trip a trip wire okay
so it's almost like a lot of scam
artists out there no they're not a scam
artist
there's a lot of time wasters out there
right so they like the idea
um second uncle's best friend's cousin
said that he's looking for a piece of
land and they're thinking oh
i think maybe i'll be able to get in on
it somehow as a jv and then just send
you out
looking frantically but they actually i
mean listen
there's also a lot of serious investors
that have got
millions of looking dives but don't be i
wouldn't get excited about someone just
saying something without proof of funds
and id and then if they give you that
they'll be taking a fee off them upfront
and even on smaller dealers you can do
this if someone says to you i'm looking
for a
brr deal in manchester and i've got 200
rounds in the bank and i just want to
find a nice deal
you could you can put them on a bespoke
sourcing package which is really good
because
it just where you just say look all
right look how about this
um let me see your id and let me see
your proof of funds
excellent and next i'm gonna spend four
weeks trying to find something give me
one thousand pounds
and then if i find something i'll i'll
i'll ask for the remaining fee which
would be two thousand pounds because my
entire fee will be three thousand
so i'll take one thousand pound up front
and then i'll search for you and
anything i find that's decent
i'll pass you away and then that way
what you're doing
is you're going out there looking for
deals
and then anything you find you're
passing them to your bespoke investors
and you don't need a massive list of
investors you only need three or four of
those people and then boom
you know you you're good and then when
you find deals
you know from estate agents you're able
to say to the estate agent look i'm
actually
um i'm actually a cash buyer you know
your situation rather than just being a
bit like lost
so yeah i think i think that's probably
what i would
what i would recommend doing i don't
know if that's helpful
yeah and so um i was told on the land
deals that
if the so the seller of the land
gives you a percentage for finding the
buyer and
so the lady that i spoke to on friday
she said they pay a standard four
percent you can negotiate
and so does that sound right
yeah so you can there are people that
will pay you a fee for finding a buyer
the only thing is i don't know what the
rules are on it but
um there might be a rule against it but
just generally speaking just even
ethically and morally i think when
you're charging a fee to the buyer and a
fee to the seller there's a bit of a
conflict of interest because
[Music]
here's what it comes down to it comes
down to who is your client
the person that's paying you money is
your client and they're the person that
you're
interested about you're you're going to
serve their best interest so if the
landowner
is saying to you i'll give you four
percent to find me a buyer your client
and your customer and the person that
you're trying to get the best deal for
is the landowner if the investor's
paying you a fee
then your client the person that you're
trying to get the best deal for
is the is the buyer so if you're if
you're buying from an estate agent the
estate agent's going to charge the
seller a fee that's fine because
you're not getting any of that fee if
you're charging both parties a fee
i don't i i don't know if there's a
illegal if if it's illegal but i would
definitely say
it's bad business practice and i
wouldn't i would recommend it
i wouldn't do that um
yeah yeah i'm a very ethical person and
i just do
absolutely have no things in double
charging i just wanted to check if it
was right that
the seller pays you a percentage but
okay i've missed the point that really
that if they're paying me the percentage
it's the seller of the land that's my
client over and above
the um that the person buying the land
yeah and introducing them but i would be
okay to put in place something to say
look if you ever want to buy another
piece of land
you two can't deal with each other
without cutting
absolutely yeah you can if i were you i
would be saying
right i'll be saying my goal is i want
to get three people
to pay me some money in the next two
weeks
to be honest i've set myself a weak
target well there we go even better
even better even better but if you get
along the way
any you know anytime you get stuck i
mean you can book these calls unlimited
as a samuel 365 member you can jump on a
call
um they are 15 minutes i'm gonna have to
wrap up because i've got another call
um scheduled but anytime you get stuck
any specific questions or anything you
need at all
just book a call and um and we'll be
here to help and assist you along the
way
perfect okay yeah
brilliant and if i needed help with that
is that something you would help
partners
me not just me but i mean this community
everyone in the community everyone's
open to business including myself
perfect
thanks so much
[Music]